[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime-doku von
Bild
hello again ich bin Tony und ich bin
Mirco wie versprochen geht es heute
weiter mit Teil 2 der Geschichte des
totmachers mit Rudolf Pleil aus dem
Erzgebirge der in den Wirren des Zweiten
Weltkrieges auf Schiffen diente und zum
Alkoholiker wurde ein Mann den beim
erschlagen und verspeisen von Katzen
klar wurde dass es ihm Spaß macht zu
töten gegen Ende des Krieges wurde er
beim Klauen erwischt und bei ihm wurde
Epilepsie diagnostiziert als Deutschland
schon in Besatzungszonen aufgeteilt ist
schlägt er sich im Südharz als
Schmuggler durch und als Führer für
Menschen die von Ost nach West wollen
privat steckt er gerade in seiner
zweiten Beziehung mit seiner Frau hat er
eine kleine Tochter Blei wird später
behaupten dass er schon in der ersten
Jahreshälfte 1945
kleine Morde begangen hat aber das wird
nie nachgewiesen seinen ersten Mord oder
den ersten für den er mit Sicherheit
verantwortlich gemacht werden kann den
begeht er am 19 juli 1946 im Wald
zwischen den Örtchen Walkenried und
Ellrich erschlägte eine etwa 25-jährige
Frau mit einem Hammer danach vergeht er
sich an seinem schwer verletzten oder
möglicherweise schon Totenopfer bei
seinen nächsten Morgen ist er nicht
allein er begeht sie mit zwei Kumpanen
Karl Hoffmann und Konrad Schüssler
gutaussehende Vertrauen erweckende
Männer sie helfen wenn es darum geht das
Vertrauen von Frauen zu gewinnen die
Hilfe beim Überqueren der Zonengrenze
suchen
19 August 1946 Pleil und Hoffmann locken
eine 25-jährige Frau im oberfränkischen
Hof auf das Gelände des Güterbahnhofs
Hoffmann schlägt ihr mit seinem Messer
den Kopf ein während Pleil sie
vergewaltigt dann schneidet Hoffmann ihr
die Kehle durch
2 september 1946 bei einem Grenzgang
begegnen Pleil und Hoffmann einer Frau
sie ist wie die beiden letzten Opfer 25
Jahre alt Pleil erschlägt sie mit einem
Feldstein und vergibt sich an der Toten
Hoffmann verscharrt die Leiche im Wald
Mitte September 1946 treffen sie erneut
eine 25-jährige die allein unterwegs ist
anscheinend eine schwarzhändlerin sie
begleiten sie ein Stück des Weges dann
ermordet Hoffmann sie und raubt sie aus
anschließend schneidet er ihr den Kopf
ab im November 1946 verspricht Kleider
Jungfrau Christa Schneider sie über die
Grenze zu schleusen obwohl bleibe
betrunken ist lässt sich die Frau darauf
ein unterwegs trinkt er weiter und
erleidet einen epileptischen Anfall als
er wieder zu sich kommt liegt die Frau
erschlagen neben ihm am 14 Dezember
töten Pleil und Schüßler eine 37-jährige
am 19 Dezember eine 44-jährige Witwe die
Leichen werfen sie in einen Brunnen nahe
dem Bahnhof von wienburg
am 16 januar 1947 stirbt eine junge Frau
die sich Pleil und Hoffmann für einen
Grenzübertritt anvertraut hat
Mitte Februar erschlagen und berauben
die beiden eine 49-jährige Anfang März
töten sie auf der Ostseite der Grenze
eine Frau die nie identifiziert werden
konnte Hoffmann trennt ihr anschließend
den Kopf ab Anfang März 47 beginnt Pleil
und Hoffmann in der Nähe von Zorge
innerhalb der sowjetisch besetzten Zone
einen weiteren Frauen Mord
Hoffmann tötet eine unbekannte junge
Frau mit seinem Messer und trennt ihr
anschließend den Kopf ab ihren Kopf
findet man später im britischen Sektor
diese schreckliche Liste das sind die
Frauenmorde für die Peil später
verurteilt wird einige ihrer Opfer
werden aber nie identifiziert und das
ist auch nicht groß verwunderlich ich
meine das ist eine Zeit in der in
Deutschland hunderttausende entwurzelt
sind und ihre Angehörigen suchen und Tag
für Tag Morde geschehen und die
Polizeiarbeit zu diesem Zeitpunkt ist
extrem schwierig zum einen befindet sich
eine neue Polizei erst im Aufbau und
dann ist da das Problem mit den
Zonengrenzen für die Polizisten im
Westen enden die Ermittlungen an der
Grenze zum sowjetischen Sektor es gibt
keinerlei Zusammenarbeit mit den
Behörden drüben im Osten was ich
besonders deutlich beim letzten
Frauenmord von Pleil und Hoffmann zeigt
selbst als Körper und Kopf des Opfers
auf verschiedenen Seiten der Grenze
gefunden werden
schwiegern die Behörden im Osten die
Kooperation wir möchten wenigstens einer
dieser Frauen einen Namen und eine
Geschichte geben Gertrud Glöde ihre
Lebensgeschichte und ihr Schicksal sind
gut dokumentiert Ende 1946 ist sie 44
Jahre alt sie hat eine zehnjährige
Tochter Elvira mit der ist sie aus dem
zerbomben Berlin zu ihrer Mutter nach
Vienenburg geflohen vom Vater fehlt
monatelang jede Spur im Herbst 1946 wird
die große Angst dann zur Gewissheit ihr
Mann ist tot am 14 Dezember macht sich
Gertrud auf den Weg nach Berlin dort
will sie die Wohnung auflösen zu
Weihnachten bin ich wieder da verspricht
sie ihre Tochter die bei der Oma
zurückbleibt und ich bringe dir was
Schönes mit der Grenzübertritt gelingt
unbehellig gelangt sie in den Osten
vielleicht ist sie auf ihrem Weg am
Bahnwärterhäuschen von wienburg
vorbeigekommen in dem in derselben Nacht
Rudolf Bleil und Konrad füßler eine
andere Frau ermorden und ihre Leiche in
ein Brunnen werfen
Werbung heute möchten wir euch
Wolfskinder das Thrillerdebüt von
Autoren Vera Buck vorstellen er Schienen
ist das Buch beim robert-verlag in dem
Buch verschwinden immer wieder Frauen in
einem abgeschiedenen Ort in den Bergen
einer Siedlung fernab von der modernen
Welt hier gelten die Regeln der Natur
rau und erbarmungslos nun möchte die
junge Journalistin Smilla die vor Jahren
ihre Freundin juli in der Gegend
verloren hat der Wahrheit auf die Spur
kommen erst recht als ihr ein
verwahrlostes Mädchen vors Auto läuft
das verblüffende Ähnlichkeit mit Julia
hat und schon bald kommt Smilla einem
schockierenden Geheimnis auf die Spur
das alle vermeintlichen Wahrheiten aus
den Angeln hebt wo lauert das Böse
wirklich mit großer Sprachkraft und
psychologischer Tiefe erzählt Vera Bug
von menschlichen Abgründen erzählt ist
das Buch aus sechs Perspektiven und
bildet durch das atmosphärisch
bedrohliche bergsetting die perfekte
abgeschiedene Kulisse für diesen
furiosen Thriller also große
Leseempfehlung für Wolfskinder von Vera
Buck
Werbung Ende
die Haushaltsauflösung in Berlin gelingt
Gertrud Glöde kann einige Habseligkeiten
und Dokumente mitnehmen und irgendwie
gelingt es ihr auch eine kleine Puppe
aufzutreiben ein Geschenk für ihre
Tochter um an Weihnachten in diesem
schrecklichen Jahr vielleicht doch noch
ein Leuchten in ihrer Augen zu zaubern
und sie die Not und die Trauer um den
Vater vergessen zu lassen auf dem
Rückweg lässt sie ein Großteil der
Sachen bei einer Bekannten auf der
Ostseite der Grenze zurück sollte man
sie erwischen würde alles konfisziert
und dieses Risiko will sie nicht
eingehen aber das allerwichtigste bleibt
in ihrem Rucksack die Puppe aber Elvira
wird die Puppe nie erhalten und ihre
Mutter nie wieder sehen
am 19 dezember 1946 auf dem letzten
Abschnitt ihrer Reise gerade einmal zwei
Kilometer von dem Haus entfernt in dem
ihre Tochter sehnsüchtig ihre Rückkehr
erwartet er schlägt sie Pleil und wirft
ihre Leiche ebenfalls in den Brunnen an
der alten Bahnlinie die Puppe aus
gertruds Rucksack schenkt Pleil seiner
dreijährigen Tochter genau das sind die
Details die die Fälle so furchtbar
machen das ist der Moment in dem dieser
Fall plötzlich eine Geschichte und aus
den Opfern und Tätern Menschen werden
weißt du was ich meine natürlich man hat
ja plötzlich Bilder vor Augen eine
zehnjährige bei ihrer Oma die dort
sehnsüchtig auf die Mutter wartet und
dann ist da ja auch noch die andere
Perspektive und zwar das andere Mädchen
dessen Augen leuchten als ihr Vater ihr
eine Puppe schenkt und das natürlich
nicht ahnt welches Grauen dahinter
steckt Elvira erfährt erst paar Monate
später dass sie ihre Mutter nie wieder
sehen wird die Großmutter meldet Gertrud
als vermisst doch die Suche bleibt
erfolglos in der Nacht des 13 April 1947
führt Pleil einen Kaufmann aus Hamburg
über die Grenze in den Osten zumindest
versucht er es den Pleil ist stark
angetrunken als der Kaufmann bemerkt
dass sie sich verlaufen haben und in die
falsche Richtung gehen da kommt es zum
Streit kleil zieht eine Axt aus dem
Rucksack und erschlägt den Kaufmann
es ist sein letzter Mord Zeugen haben
ihn und den Kaufmann zuvor im
Braunschweiger Hof in Zorge trinken
sehen und die Axt kann ihm zugeordnet
werden am 18 April wird Pleil verhaftet
niemand ahnt wie man da wirklich
geschnappt hat
Rudolf Pleil wird wegen des Mordes an
dem Hamburger der Prozess gemacht das
Gericht entscheidet auf Totschlag da er
zum Tatzeitpunkt stark angetrunken war
und verurteilt ihn zu zwölf Jahren Haft
12 Jahre also er wäre spätestens 1959
wieder auf freiem Fuß da wäre er 35
Jahre alt doch Pleil sorgt selbst dafür
dass es dazu nicht kommt ja und jetzt
wird es wirklich bezahlbar wir haben
hier ja schon einige wirklich irre
Geschichten erzählt und oft ging es da
um Täter mit Ja sagen wir mal vorsichtig
ausgedrückt übersteigert im
Selbstbewusstsein und einem völlig
verzerrten Realitätssinn aber sowas ich
glaube das hatten wir noch nicht leute
haltet euch gut fest aus dem Gefängnis
heraus bewirbt sich Pleil um eine Stelle
als Henker
vielleicht ganz kurz zum Hintergrund die
Todesstrafe wurde im Westen Deutschlands
erst 1949 mit Einführung des
Grundgesetzes abgeschafft als Pleil
verurteilt wird gibt es sie noch weshalb
die Gerichtsentscheidung auf Totschlag
im nicht nur eine relativ kurze
Haftstrafe einbringt sondern ihn auch
vor der Hinrichtung bewahrt und jetzt
will er andere hinrichten und wie es
sich für eine gute Bewerbung gehört fügt
er Referenzen bei dabei bezichtigt er
sich selbst mehrere Frauenmorde
das ist so absurd zu Recht nimmt niemand
seine Bewerbung ernst und das passt ihm
nicht er schreibt also einen Brief an
den Bürgermeister von wienburg Zitat an
den Bürgermeister von wienburg
ich habe mich schon an den hiesigen Chef
gewendet dass er mir die Todeskandidaten
überlässt die glauben mir nicht dass ich
ein Mann bin der gut und schnell tot
machen kann
auf der Strecke von Vienenburg nach
Abbenrode steht ein
eisenbahnwärterhäuschen da habe ich die
alte mit einem großen Schraubenschlüssel
auf den Kopf gekitzelt und umgelegt er
fügt sogar eine Skizze bei in den er den
Brunnen einzeichnet indem er die Leichen
von Gertrud glödel und einer weiteren
Frau geworfen hat und dann schließt er
den Brief mit beeilen Sie sich mit dem
Auffinden der Leichen Unterschrift
Rudolf Pleil Totmacher ade so ein Idiot
aber ich glaube das wird dadurch so
besonders wahnsinnig dass er selbst ja
durchaus irgendwie eine Logik dabei hat
ja Wahnsinn und Logik schließen sich
nicht unbedingt aus in Vienenburg pumpt
man nun den alten Brunnen aus Pleil hat
die Wahrheit gesagt zwei Frauen Leichen
mit zertrümmerten Schädeln werden
geborgen und für die kleine Elvira wird
nach Monaten der Ungewissheit der
schlimmste Albtraum war ihre Mutter ist
tot
man bringt das Mädchen zur Polizei nach
Braunschweig dort muss sie die
Kleidungsstücke ihrer Mutter
identifizieren
gegen Pleil wird neue Anklage erhoben
diesmal wegen der Frauenmorde anfangs
verweigert er die Zusammenarbeit dann
fängt er an Informationen gegen kleine
Vergünstigungen wie besseres Essen
preiszugeben und schließlich sprudelt es
nur so aus dem heraus er gesteht
insgesamt 40 Morde von denen er einige
nachweislich nicht begangen haben kann
er verschafft sich Ausflüge indem er die
Polizei zu tatau führt er besteht darauf
als der todmacher angeredet zu werden
und posiert im Gefängnis für ein Foto
stolz schaut in die Kamera deinem langen
Zettel die Liste der Morde die er für
sich beansprucht außerdem schreibt er
seine Memo an und gibt ihnen den Titel
Mein Kampf also wie Hitlers
verachtenswerte Kampfschrift und auch
dieses Buch ist unerträglich geprägt von
sexueller Gewalt Frauen hast und
absoluter menschlicher Kälte
er sieht sich nicht nur als größter
Totmacher sondern auch als
Schriftsteller Philosoph und Psychologe
es ist schon die Sache mit der Seele und
den Heringen und sogar als Humorist er
schreibt eine Komödie über sein Leben ja
wenn man weiß was er getan hat ist das
wirklich abartig er lässt sich auch beim
schreiben fotografieren mit Kleider und
Stift in der Hand und diesem Lächeln im
runden Kindergesicht
ich möchte noch ein Zitat aus dr
Barnstorf Spiegelartikel von 1950
vorlesen
ich habe noch nie so grauenhaft deutlich
die abnorm mit trieb Entladung sich
enthüllen sehen wie in einer
unheimlichen Szene als der untersetzte
verfettete junge Bursche in
erstaunlicher Behändigkeit und
Gewandtheit mit seiner in Form eines
menschlichen Körpers auf den Boden
gebreiteten Jacke und Hose eine stumme
pantomima agierte in der er die
erschlagung und sexuelle Misshandlung
einer Frau spielte dabei genießerisch
kicherte und hinterher erklärte diesen
Fall einer Bearbeitung so nennt er seine
sadistischen Misshandlungen der toten
Opfer habe er noch nicht gestanden
[Musik]
am 17 November werden Pfeil und seine
beiden Mitglieder zu lebenslange Haft
verurteilt
1958 macht sich Der Totmacher in seiner
Zelle selber tot
Karl Hofmann stirbt 1976 im Gefängnis
Konrad Schüssler wird Ende der 70er
Jahre begnadigt ziemlich harter Tobak
und das war's für heute ja und das
reicht auch ganz ehrlich
also wenn ich das so ein Fall als Frau
höre ich spreche hier nicht laut aus was
ich gerne mit ihm tun würde aber weißt
du Mirko nach so einer Geschichte hätte
ich fast Lust hier meine Folge über
einen handtaschend Diebstahl oder ein
Falschparker oder so zu machen oder
jemanden der seine GEZ nicht zahlt
irgendwas harmloses ich weiß nicht ob
das unsere Zuhörer so interessiert wie
spannende Kriminalfälle natürlich haben
wir es ja immer wieder mit wirklich
extremen Fällen zu tun aber ja da hast
du Recht das interessiert sie nicht
wirklich und ich meine wir machen das ja
auch hier weil diese Geschichten so
unfassbar erschütternd und gleichzeitig
faszinierend sind und
da darf man aber auch trotzdem mal sagen
dass einem sowas an die Nieren geht ja
natürlich allein die Geschichte von der
Puppe das ist so traurig und entsetzlich
das bleibt auf jeden Fall hängen ja und
das ist auch ein Zeichen Mirko dass wir
eine Seele haben und er nicht recht hat
mit seinem Zitat dass eine Seele nur
Heringen vorbehalten ist das hast du
super gesagt ein sehr schönes
Schlusswort Liebe Toni wir danken euch
dass ihr wieder dabei wart für die
Geschichte des Massenmörders Rudolf
Pfeil haben wir unter anderem folgende
Quellen verwendet der Fall Pleil von dr
med Fritz Barnstorf im Spiegel Nummer 45
von 1950 die ARD-Doku Der Totmacher
Rudolf von Hans-Dieter Rutsch und das
Buch nur Heringe haben eine Seele von
Fred Selin
danke dass ihr dabei wart und das
nächste Mal wird es sicher nicht um
Handtaschen Diebstähle oder Falschparker
gehen das versichere ich euch bis dann
eure Toni und euer Mirko
Redaktion Stephan Nettebad Skript und
Postproduktion durch die weight watch
Studios München Schnitt